San Diego: it's California's second largest city and it's an idyllic place for vacation.
The people are friendly, it's full of history and there's rarely a crowd.
This is the San Diego Zoo...
...just minutes from downtown San Diego.
It's an urban oasis with over 3,000 different animal species.
Definitely get the backstage pass here at the zoo.
It is the most hands-on experience you can have.
Spend an entire week just exploring all there is to do here in Balboa Park.
Art museums, bike trails and that's just the beginning.
Old Town San Diego is considered the birthplace of California.
It's the site of the first Spanish settlement in the state.
Much of the town has been preserved; it's like stepping back in time.
This is the San Diego of the 1800s.